mai startet wetter besprechen das herz
von europa max grundig stapel ja meine
leute und herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren video der playlist conny
unterwegs ich habe jetzt mal so eine
playlist gemacht aber nicht unterwegs
münchen hamburg frankfurt berlin die
bereits ein bisschen robuster gründen
jedenfalls war ich heute nach frankfurt
zu max krankhafter den besuchen ja was
lediglich mit 100 musikern
ich stehe gerade beim kamener kreuzes
selber etwas los weil wenn sich alle
einordnungen wollen und es ist gerade 12
53 dann geht das nicht so gut ihr seht
also ein bisschen stoppen und gleich bin
ich bei max hoffentlich mal irgendwann
so gegen mitternacht drei oder so und
dann werde ich filmen wenn ich bei ihm
bin und alles mögliche und jetzt ich
hatte ja auch immer diese leute diesen
linke spur blockiert wäre das alles
nicht passiert wenn ich nicht der halbe
stelle ankomme so schwach die frau
verlinkten sportler ja ich habe jetzt
kann man das cabrio aufgemacht weil ich
fahre ja ein cabrio und
ich stecke nicht im stau deshalb eine
umleitung eingegeben und war es jetzt
auch stehen wie jeder eingegeben hat und
jetzt bin ich so denke ich schon mal da
ist jetzt dreieinhalb stunden auto und
dann werden wir gleich mal schauen was
machst du dich machen und wahrscheinlich
werde mir nach frankfurt gehen bisschen
schnell nicht werden die schuhe kaufen
müssen weil ich endlich mal ein paar
sachen am main stellen und das ist quasi
jetzt auch in frankfurt wieder kreise
denkt ich bin jetzt bei max angekommen
ich habe da so ein paar videos
mitgenommen die ich bei max hochladen
möchte
das ist übrigens gebt euch das mal alter
zwei minuten vergab not bei mir stehen
dahinter
kommentar ab sie die bayern nicht mehr
geht es mit fischer dass da irgendwie
groß aussieht wir sind jetzt bei maxxim
keller wir sehen hier ist relativ cool
da steht fernseher das bettchen und hier
mädchen.de ich bin ich was kann ich tun
hier ist jedenfalls sehr der max er hat
immer ganz gute frage deswegen vertreter
nicht mehr hier und so wie du halo 3 6
wir sind willkommen viele kaufen ich
muss mir was muss denn noch holen und
ich sehe du dass du etwas der jungen
paar anständige schuhe kauft die
neumodisch ja ich habe ja aus diesem
wasserfest ging es ab nach frankfurt und
dann kommt jetzt einen monitor
die erste frage kommt von antje racer at
rancho chiemsee adcom kräfte was werdet
ihr im urlaub alles machen
habt ihr vor also ich antworten als
erstes um zu erfahren wie ihr
zusammenhalt nicht nur wir beide sondern
mit vielen anderen und wir werden da
viele coole sachen machen wir werden uns
beispielsweise wollen wir uns
wasserpistole kauf und am strand so ein
bisschen bei sonnenuntergang mit gopro
drauf kann über dabei deswegen vielen
fällen mit pröll darauf an so ein
bisschen rum schießen darf wird
wahrscheinlich ein cooles video
entscheiden dann so ein bisschen am
strand polizei spielen halt wirklich
eigentlich immer den ganzen tag strand
und abends irgendwie so rumlaufen
ich hätte auf jeden fall so ein paar
sachen film auch kriechen longboard
zugesendet von einem unternehmen aus
schweden
das ist keine produktplatzierungen habe
ich mir bestellt und da werde ich
eventuell auch noch ein review zu drehen
und wenn das kommt an wenn ich dann im
urlaub bin das habe ich extra zu den
adressen urlaub bestellten da werde ein
bisschen mit kruse und das wären im
urlaub alles macht was ist dein
lieblingstier fragt wieviel affe wollte
ich habe letztens echt mal in einem tier
dingsbums ein lexikon nachgeguckt mit
affen die man die pflegt und was man da
braucht aber man darf in deutschland
irgendwie nicht halten
irgendwie keine ahnung ich hätte ihm
unglaublich gerne affen sonst mein
zweites lieblings haus die wie eine
schildkröte vier plexi fragt wirst du
irgendwann mal ein livestream machen
ja wenn ich in hamburg wohne habe ich
eine 50.000 der leitung und dann kann
ich besonders stream dann wird
vielleicht auch mal der 200.000 aber ich
brauch 200.000 gar videos hochgeladen
und die video von schneller oben als ich
die beschreibung machen konnte
ein bisschen crazy fliegen kann dir weil
du so stinkt markus pinger fragt wenn
man ein budget von 100 euro hättest
würdest du ein studium mike oder ein
headset empfehlen 100 euro definitiv
fliegen weg gefunden
100 euro würde ich sagen also also
headset würde ich nie gehen wenn man
aufnehmen will nie ein headset also
wollen mit mit face konsumenten headset
einfach so unpraktisch weil ihr wollte
die aufmerksamkeit auf euch und ich habe
am anfang studien mikrofon empfohlen für
60 euro tiefer und sc 404 tiere sohn des
volkes und damit habe ich bis vor kurzem
release macht und dann habe ich so neues
entdeckt ja das liegt ja auch in fulda
zu kaufen ich sehe ja ich hab das mikro
entdeckt also ja ich hab's rat bestellt
würdet ihr euch ein leben ohne euch bei
ducati
kein sind die hits miriam aber bitte da
hast du schon mal ein straßenschild
gestohlen ja zwei stück habe ich in der
garage rumstehen
die nimmt man bei uns immer mit wenn man
wolle dass er keine straßenschilder
jeder von uns hat keiner von mir hat
irgendwann ein stoppschild in einer
gerade stehen und alles mögliche
verletzlich welche farbe hat meine
zahnbürste nämlich gar nicht wenige putz
keine ahnung weiß-blaue glaube ich ist
zügeln
lieber in der stadt oder am strand
wurden strand also wenn ich wirklich die
bleibe am strand wurden und hinterlistig
staat ja dass das wollte ich auch sagen
wenn ich die wahl hätte zwischen strand
und wirklich in der stadt dann will ich
auf jeden fall den strand jeweils da
ruhiger ist lag hier mit offener oder
geschlossener tür geschlossen
schlimm ist nicht das dass sie jeder
rein kommen könnte sondern dass morgen
in welchen anderen youtube mann hast du
am meisten kontakt aufgetaucht die weise
verschwunden die aufstiegs wird es also
macht halt wir waren halt freunde bevor
er youtube gemacht hat und der youtuber
jaja geht sitzen jeweils vor drei jahren
schon kanal
also jedenfalls mag setzt mittlerweile
weil youtuber ist und sonst so wie ich
über youtube kennengelernt habe habe ich
mit sehr wenigen kontakt was ich wohne
auch voll am arsch der welt deswegen
kann ich doch nicht irgendwas zu ihm hin
fahren oder so ich werde mal schauen wie
sich das entwickelt wenn ich in der
hamburger sind auch eine youtube ein
paar leute mit dem ich auf jeden fall
was machen werde fcb
champions-league-finale ist ein guter
name werdet ihr eure longboards mit in
den urlaub nehmen um ein longboard habe
ich ja eh nur von einem freund
ausgeliehen gehabt also das war gar
nicht meins und ich bekomme ja in den
urlaub ich schon gesagt habe neues
zugesendet und das ist halt kein
longboard sondern das ist das ja auch
keinen penny penny bord ist hast dich
eigentlich weil das komplett aus plastik
ist das was ich kriege es hat wirklich
so das ist aus einem bambus bauern
gemacht und das ist gewiss am trampolin
so dass schon ein richtiger also das
werde ich auf jeden fall haben und du
wirst keine und indem wir da auch so
kannst du nicht so gut fahre ich wieder
probieren fand vor dem kopfsteinpflaster
leider die letzte frage kommt von yasin
router und zwar herstellers conny wieso
hast du bei minecraft 1 kind mit einer
maske weil das sieht extrem komisch aus
das hat sich damals so ergeben ich habe
eine animation von slezak auge sehen wo
es die idee ist emerald trading könnt
ihr gern vorbeigucken ist super gerne
animation und da ist halt wirklich so
ein typ der sich als williger verkleidet
und er will dann halt so ein bisschen
handel mit villiger kann man halt so
handel mit smaragden und so ist er und
das dann dieser typ der ist als zwei
deswegen ist der letzte dieser zwei von
team fortress weil ich hab das damals
auch richtig viel gezockt ich zock das
auch immer noch mit ihm ich liebe team
fortress alter muss vielleicht mehr
unterland sind jedenfalls ist dieser
spyder halt auch von blauen anzug ins
ohr und erteilten der will ja maske auf
weil er sich als williger ausgibt und ja
deswegen habe ich finde richtig geil ich
hab dann aber noch ein bisschen heller
gemacht so kontrast bisschen höhere
helligkeit überbelichtung dass ein
bisschen cool aussieht und ja da war von
den fragen jetzt werden wir noch viele
halter was auch schön hier jedenfalls
fahren wir jetzt nach frankfurt einfach
alter sieht man so gar nicht mal so
häufig
wir fahren jetzt nach frankfurter für
mich auch so ein paar sachen und an wen
wir uns da wir sind in frankfurt
angekommen
wir bräuchten die kamera am anfang war
da nicht schön aus muss ich sagen okay
jetzt hier vorne man sieht wieder nur
das gebäude wegen dienstlicher einmal
auf den echten porsche gebäude wir
fahren jetzt nach frankfurt
beziehungsweise sind jetzt dabei wär ich
muss mir schuhe kauft werden die zeit
einfach die zeit auf die einkaufsstraße
wir wollen eigentlich auch schon
hochhaus drauf gehen weil ich unbedingt
111 zum hoch aus machen möchte aber die
haben wahrscheinlich zu wald schon 18
uhr ist 18 33 und hallo fahren das alter
nach frankfurt ich war die ganze bekannt
dass die ampel grün wie du nicht kammer
dessen ausmachen kann aber sie hat
einfach nicht gewöhnen dass es kritisch
hallo wir sind im park aus
und gestern gleich was in frankfurt hat
wahrscheinlich schon die skyline gesehen
du dir stehen echt schöner autos steht
ein q7 s-line sonntagen und jetzt
checken wir sind in frankfurt max mara
dran und da
egal das höchste gebäude deutschland
rate ich möchte mit drauf haben das ist
das höchste
die laufen jetzt noch ein bisschen rum
ihr seht jetzt wahrscheinlich sachen ich
melde mich gleich wenn ihr das essen das
sie einfach verpasst
das ist die einfachste und das windows
vor allem frei nach oben müssen wir den
jungen gerade durch total männlichen
laden ich musste das jetzt einfach mal
film
das ist genau dann zu hause
also ich meine
wir sind nicht gerade in so einem
riesigen tut das gebäude
und ich muss sagen frankfurt ist zwar
nicht schön
echt nicht geil aber es ist einfach
konfus und riesig
wir haben gerade und ganz einfach auch
für die mutter in calais ach so heißt
das hat ja nicht wichtiger der petri
in paris wo sind wir wohl in frankfurt
auf der zeil
heute ist das wenn man im moment machst
du denn so sauber sind sauber
hier laufen immer noch durch frankfurt
und das erst richtig unangenehm und
kamera so weit vor sich hin dass
natürlich wenn man hier so heldt nein du
machst wir haben uns dinge geholt von
starbucks ihr wisst ihr was ich esse
trinke und er hat einfach gesagt er
halte auch luca ist in ordnung ich
weitermache sagte er nicht
ich habe gesagt er heißt auch luca und
ich weiß dass nur soll sich so ja wie
schwer ihr business trackers
ich schwöre das hat einen hinteren ab
die fast komisch weil er einfach aber
ich werde k geschrieben deren luca mit k
bekommt gar keinen sinn jetzt noch
weiter durch frankfurt und suchen jetzt
ab
wenn ihr wisst apple ist schreibt uns
nicht runter weil zu wenig
das salz aus wir sind immer noch in
hamburg frankfurt maxi kontakt dahinter
ist die alte oper durch das blödes
dieses fischer objektiv die alte oper
aha durch die zwischen objektiv geht
einfach alles klein aus auch wenn dinge
richtig hoch sind
da oben dahinter seht ihr ein relativ
hohes gebäude und da auch
das liegt einfach alles relativ klein
aus dadurch dass dieses fischer objektiv
das ganze weit wie nötig gemacht und er
ja ich könnte auch das plus klicken
aber nicht während des films meinung
aber wir befinden uns gerade alte opa
seht ihr ja schon
und wir wollen gleich so ein bisschen
wir haben übrigens grad von red bull was
kredit bekommen wir kriegen ja nicht so
dass wir das zeigen die kam nur so anja
wollte kostenlose tool und max einfach
so natürlich wir wir sind ja wir leben
die ironie mag sagte ja nee wir wollen
das kauf und wie so was
das haben wir nicht und so eine ddr zu
vernehmen dass und ich sehe versteckte
kamera kommt es während sony kommt nicht
ins meer sind wachse kommen wir auch auf
youtube wie sollen wir wollten schon
immer mal und deshalb nehmen wir es
jetzt ins spiel weil wir doch auch die
tante von red bull renner des east wir
hätten dich voller elan haben und wir
uns gratis
die belichtung ist echt cool des
berichts back office and jump und da
werden wir ihm auf
zakumi uns hier genannten unternehmen
die tiefe
da sind wir und damit werden
es könnte dahin setzen mit dem tisch
bestreichen und denken dabei kommt der
punkt antreten
hier sind wir gerade so sieht das ja aus
und jetzt erfolge sitzung hat beim
subway in frankfurt falls dieses appells
es geht da nicht hin zur verkäuferin
haben keine ahnung die wusste nicht mal
so
ich sagte ja mit salz und pfeffer bitte
weil sie das uns vergessen hätte sie
passen ungefähr da wo ich aber immer
noch mal sagen die war scheiße
die haben wir zwei brotsorten von sieben
glaub ich davon 6
das hat mich lange gedauert die ganzen
tomaten zu warnen darin verteilt werden
sollen weil sie nicht reich kacke und ja
wir wollten eigentlich erst der anfang
so viel pro jahr bietet jetzt oben auf
dieser bahn weil wir doch nicht
hingegangen weil die realisiert haben
dass das ein restaurant ist und werden
kein weiter so gesittet zu essen
deswegen wird auf jeden fall wissen was
erlebt vielleicht waren wir auch nach
frankfurt machen
und darum
wir laufen immer noch durch frankfurt
wir waren gerade bei subway ist sehr
wahrscheinlich gesehen habe und jetzt
sind wir auf einer straße nicht mehr als
viel los ist weil wir jetzt auch gleich
zum denker laufenden vertrag aus guck
mal jedenfalls aber wie dicke egal
jedenfalls laufen jetzt zurück zu dem
paar koffer gepackt haben jedem land
wenn ihr richtig schönen lebens um den
straßen weil die ganzen das auch so da
wo ich in hamburg die wohnung habe
da sind überall solche worte leben keine
schuhe alter sowie entdecke ich immer
wieder andere sachen auf der rechten
seite ich schaue jetzt einfach nicht
mehr hin
jedenfalls da wir sind immer noch im
nahen wald also halt deine schnauze
junge honig sagst du junge zu dir zu
schauen
überall wo wir hin laufen er sagt
einfach so da kommt ein sport wo er
hinläuft also ich will jetzt wo wir sind
und ich habe ihn erst geglaubt aber
total verlaufen aber damals bei
starbucks und so etwas ist einfach immer
wieder voll da sind überall hochhäuser
und das ist sehr sehr pompös und groß
aus und wie laufen zurück zum parkhaus
benannte zorc und dann sehen wir uns
dort wieder
wir sind gerade wieder bei max rauser
kommen dem altbekannten kenne ich habe
mir letztes eu gekauft die wahl kaputt
nach zwei minuten
ich habe jetzt so neue bekommen wären
das schon getestet die funktioniert und
mario kart das richtig geil dass max und
wir liegen jetzt bist du da rum und wir
wollen gleich noch dieses video die
videos hier bearbeiten und noch ein paar
sachen machen
labern [ __ ] max heftig und hässlich
übrigens hat max ist auch das mikrofon
was ich mir eventuell auch jung wollte
und 20 - vor allem max hat damals mich
angeschrien hat die heute mit einem
kompressor mit komplimenten einholte das
mikrofon ist begeistert super produkt
danke danke
die kennen gar nichts für von blue oder
so dass wir das sagen ich finde das echt
schönes sieht schön aus und anderswo
nach voll ein wundervolles produkt
die sache ist halt nicht immer das ist
halt so hatten die das wirklich damals
mit radio oder das gibt zwar immer noch
im radio das ist echt ein geiles teil
es gibt halt auch eine teurere variante
die würde ich mir soll das ist das blue
bird & bird bild gibt es auch in zwei
sonder so dass blue bird es gibt das
blue bay bot es gibt ganz viele davon
aber da ich versuche mal so dass die
landwirte mein kopf ist aber dass eignet
sich halt nicht so gut fürs planen weil
fürs play ist besser wenn du so ein
bisschen genau die gleiche nicht auf
naja jedenfalls für slackline eigneten
sich das halt nicht so gut weil da immer
junge ich dachte was kommt jetzt von
hinten weil beim netz bringt ihr sind
halt immer man schreit dann kommt wieder
dass man ganz allein ist echt cool aus
und beim let's play deshalb besser diese
diese ich weiß ich dann wie die teureren
varianten sind alle podcast im radio ffh
hat hilfsteams wann machst du nicht auf
einem apple store und wir haben da waren
ein bisschen einkaufen
ich habe mir wirklich wirklich was bei
apple gekauft eine hülle von der max
meinte ich kann man sich dann so eine
hülle kaufen basiert irgendwie 35 euro
kostet aber ich zeige euch mein leben
ich finde sie sehr schön weil ich hab so
ich denke immer wenn ich in solchen
leben bin so von apple oder so ist ich
habe ja 10.000 iphone hülle geht mal mit
den daumen hoch in der schweiz in die
kommentare wenn ihr wollt dass ich mal
wieder bei meinen ganzen höhen mache und
deshalb wirklich sonne so eine hülle
sondern wirklich so metallic trinkst
darum die vista handys brocken aber dies
hier seht ihr max gerade drin in der in
dem handy ja wir fahren morgen nochmal
nach frankfurt aber ich glaube da fühl
mich nichts
wer mal ein bisschen was von frankfurt
gesehen von daher würde ich sagen ich
mach' bestimmt gleich nochmal and card
video
wenn ich aber arbeiten also seemonster
wieder okay anscheinend habe ich doch
kein ende gemacht tut mir leid habe ich
dann wohl leider vergessen
ich habe mit pizza ofen geschoben ich
bin jetzt zu hause weil heute ist schon
der tag danach der 26 gerade um 12 uhr
mitternacht
ich bearbeite das gerade alles halber
kraft gar keine nennt card irgendwie
gefunden als ich hab das total vergessen
zu machen
pizzen sind jetzt wahrscheinlich
angebrannt ganz schnelles ende wenn es
euch gefallen hat und je mehr wirklich
von solchen kombi unterwegs
die loks volt in der playlist anzeigen
mag ich und schreibt mir doch mal die
kommentare was ich am meisten gefallen
hat oder ob in welchen städten hier
schon alles was und ob ich schon in
frankfurt gewesen seid und wir euch die
stadt so gefällt ich finde es jetzt
nicht so geil ist alles sehr groß und
ich habe es im video der einmal gesagt
pompös das passende wort glaube ich wenn
es euch gefallen hat zeigt auf jeden
fall mit einer bewertung und dann sehen
wir uns in den nächsten video wieder was
sie anschauen werde
bis 18